okay so we had a very constructive
executive meeting i was delighted with
the
consensus that was achieved with all of
the executive colleagues agreeing uh to
the recommendations that michelle and i
made to them which had the support of
the department of health so from
tomorrow at midday and we will be able
to lift the rule of sex and table
service only within the hospitality
sector
as well as the guidance being lifted for
domestic settings and the cap that had
been on that and that there won't be a
cap any longer in terms of
those numbers
and also in terms of the guidance on
working from home we're reverting to
what is our baseline measure within the
autumn winter contingency plan and which
is still recognizing that you know we're
encouraging people to work from home
where you can but we accept that in some
circumstances and that isn't going to be
possible and then from
the 26th of january um at 12
noon midday and nightclubs will be able
to reopen the prohibition on dancing and
hospitality will be lifted
and also and the legal requirement and
workplaces to achieve two meters social
distancing will be lifted and then the
mandatory covert passport scheme will be
reduced to only apply in
limited circumstances that relate to
night clubs and indoor
unseated
venues of 500 people or more so
this is very welcome progress the 10th
of february will be an important meeting
now for those outstanding measures that
are still in place and until that point
um changes are to be made i encourage
people to follow the regulations
and listen to that public health advice
but i think the the public will be
pleased with these decisions that we've
been able to take it's proportionate it
reflects the changing circumstances and
that we have in respect of covet
and it is a step in the right direction
and hopefully we will continue to make
progress at our meeting on the 10th of
february
so today's decisions have been very much
informed by both the chief medical
officer and the chief scientific advisor
they've been guided by the health advice
it's very clear that we appear to be now
past the peak in terms of case numbers
but also in terms of hospital admissions
and bed occupancy so that's crucially
important information to understand why
you were able to move forward today that
alongside the fact that so many people
came forward and have achieved both
vaccines and also the booster vaccine
so it is good positive step today we do
remain cautiously optimistic but we
still ask the public to work with us
we've got to this point because of
public support we encourage that to
remain in the time ahead and we continue
to keep the remaining restrictions under
review but the 10th of february has been
earmarked as the next big staging post
if you like in terms of what happens
next but i think today's progress is to
be welcomed but it doesn't mean that we
get complacent it means that we just
double down on the remaining measures
that are there and still remain cautious